when you get down to the core of my
being I love Precious few things in this
world I love God love my
church I love my wife I love cigars and
I love Norm McDonald I think he is the
greatest standup ever to live I knew him
a little bit we actually had a very long
exchange for a period of some weeks we
would write each other these long essays
every night and I we only started doing
it because I noticed I was one of the
first people he started following on
Twitter it was it was really wild maybe
at some point I'll publish the
conversation but anyway I learned
through this correspondence that he is
even smarter was even smarter than I
thought he was completely out of nowhere
my producers decided to pull together a
bunch of nor McDonald Clips which is
fine by me cuz in my free time like if
Alisa's out of the house you know I'm
sitting eating dinner alone I'll pretty
much just put on Old reruns of nor
McDonald on
YouTube so take it away who are safer
drivers men or women well according to a
new survey 55% of adults feel that women
are most responsible for minor fender
benders while 78% blame men for most
fatal crashes please note that the
percentage in these P graphs do not add
up to 100% because the math was done by
a
woman for those of you hissing at that
joke it should be noted that that joke
was written by a woman
so now you don't know what the hell to
do
[Applause]
then no I'm just kidding we don't hire
women even back in the 90s when Norm was
hosting Weekend Update which you know
like I think his work only got better
over time I've read his book three times
I thought his podcast was terrific and
but even back then comedy doesn't always
age well and that ages so well cuz
there's always some just deeper
was a joke within a joke within a joke
keep going and finally Weekend Update
would like to congratulate Madonna who
gave birth to a beautiful baby girl last
Monday the baby weighed in at 6 lb 9 oz
making it the fourth largest object ever
to pass through Madonna's birth
[Applause]
canect even the Weekend Update holds up
well one because madana is somehow still
performing and has kept her character
exactly the same even though now she's a
woman of a certain age
but all of it you know you go back to
Old reruns of Saturday Night Live or old
comedians from the 90s and it's just so
much of it doesn't hold up but Norm free
time let's keep going all right what's
up man okay Norm you're Canadian yes I
am so what do you think of this whole
presidential mess uh well I I hope that
uh uh the Democrats don't steal the
election from the uh the winner you know
but who
knows you like George Bush I love George
Bush man he's a good man decent you know
none of
[Applause]
this and he's you know he's not a a liar
crook murderer or anything like that so
it'd be good to get the see I I don't I
think we should get the homicide out of
the White House and get like a a a fresh
start cuz we don't want any more
murderers I think we should just go on
to the next question who are the
murderers yeah oh Clinton he murdered a
guy yeah you know we're not allow you're
not allow to put accusations without
that's a little too way it let's just
let's just go on to the next question
yeah this is not my week what can I tell
you oh it's not mine either and I'm
being very nice
okay be a good boy now Norm do you never
hear that no listen we don't need to
talk I want get into this and I don't
want to hear it and this is not the
place to make those accusations and
you're supposed to be funny let's get on
exactly get there you go this is a why
show but you have been properly
chastised by Barb so I'm now going to
ask the next question I thought it was a
matter of
record look let me do this okay I'll
tell you what's a matter of record you
will not be invited back if you don't
shut up all right
now let's talk football all right man
manslaughter then the producer calls in
and drives to a bit but Norm totally
shuts it down it's so great this is the
only time that Jeremy has ever written
in to a TV show and he wrote in I forget
Jeremy was like 12 at the time and he
writes into NBC or whatever channel it's
on and says this is absolutely atrocious
like how dare they I I cannot believe
they would treat nor McDonald in this
disrespectful way just love it finally
in m in Milwaukee Wisconsin a man
allowed his 8-year-old daughter to take
the wheel of his car and an accident
ensued that damaged seven other cars and
injured six people which once again
proves my theory women can't
[Applause]
drive the on liners are great too it's
amazing that Norm is known for the
really shaggy dogs and for the onliners
so he does the Shaggy Dog you know the
uh knickknack Patty whac bit and what's
the most famous one is the uh the
Russian novel joke about the moth and
but then he also does these lines Julia
Roberts uh has recently filed for a
divorce from L love it and uh when I
asked the reason she said that uh she's
Julia Robert and he's L love you know
these really short on liners great stuff
okay next one there was a fell uh by
went by the name of uh Jac de
goer and he was from uh
taming he was smart you know he was our
hope I guess and he uh he was while I
was scrabbling to get out of high school
jacqu Zago had already I think you just
Chang his last
name well you know a man grows he he
uh he went to McGill University and he
got three degrees by golly and he went
to the over across the pond to the
fellas with Cambridge and he even stood
up to them and we thought boy he's going
to be the next but he vanished and uh I
met him uh I started to do standup and
and travel from here to there and to
here again one time I was in uh Niagara
Falls and uh by uh gosh I went over to
the um SeaWorld there you know how they
have the SeaWorld you know with the
different fish you know I didn't know
that but okay yeah yes SeaWorld I've
been there many a time okay so I was
checking out the beluga whales and stuff
and I look over and who do you think I
see I hope it's that guy no it was uh it
was just an attendant but
uh but he showed me to the place I
wanted to see which is where they feed
the the little baby dolphins because I
love Dolphins you know and who do I see
there but
ja and here he is he's feeding the baby
dolphins and I go up to him and I go ja
I get to know I I feel a shame for you
you were our hope you were to go to
Canada uh uh Canada's nation's capital
of
Ottawa and you you were to be a great
man
jaano and we were all you know we pinned
our all of all of
tbec pinned our hopes on you now that's
a that's a hell of a burden for a man to
have a Town's hope pinned on them isn't
it Conan it is a lot big burden so he
was feeding these baby dolphins you know
and I said I'm ashamed of you Jac Zano
you could have done so many great things
and he said well he said I think I'm
serving a youthful purpose now I believe
[Applause]
that
no no you I've seen like I thought every
nor McDonald's but seen this one before
but I've seen so many of them that I
actually had forgotten the punchline I
think I'm serving a youthful
ppose next one now do you think Cosby's
Legacy will be hurt yeah you do huh I
mean there was a convenient Patton
Oswald he told me I think the worst part
of The Cosby thing was the
hypocrisy and I disagreed you disagree
with that yeah I thought it was the
raping that's my feeling most rapists
are hypocrites you don't meet many go I
like raping and I I know it's not
politically correct but by God people go
well he's not being a hypocrite and
that's the worst
part I think I saw him do that one live
I saw two Norm shows one in Irvine one
with Jeremy and our producer Jonathan in
La we wore Dirty Work hats to one of
them and I think I think he did that bit
at the IR show cuz I didn't know what
Norm was going to talk about tonight and
it's this might be his most famous what
up there but he mentioned Carrot Top you
are making a movie with Carrot Top right
made a movie with Carrot Top all right
okay wait a minute she left melrose's
place to do a movie with Carrot
Top that's where I'm going my friend
this begs the question now now uh why a
movie with Carrot Top he's
extraordinarily sweet nice guy he really
is and he worked very hard and he was
adorable do you have a scene where you
and and you and him Embrace yeah lots of
making out oh for God's sake nothing but
making out all right it's like 9 and A2
weeks but Carrot
Top is it called N9 and 1 half
[Applause]
seconds like he's premature ejaculator
we got it you know but uh what's the
movie going to be called really I know
what it's going to be called yeah what's
that
if it's got katop in it you know what a
good name for it' be what's that Norm
box office
poison I'm in it too she's in it all
right well there's this 2hour season
finale of melrose's place there's this
movie coming out yes title undetermined
at this point chairman of the board oh
all right do something with that you
freak I I bet the board is spelled b o r
e
[Applause]
d i could
probably recommend three more hours of
nor McDonald bits that continue to be
great and you know I don't want to
pretend like he and I were best friends
I that would have been awesome but we we
just talked a little bit in these kind
of long essays and the guy he did this
thing where would say yeah Michael you
know you're much more educated than me
I'm completely uneducated you're very
educated and he'd be talking in this way
and then he would use a word that I
didn't know you know is like a joke with
himself he his his command of Russian
literature was outrageous he was
supposed to come on my prageru book show
book club at prageru and Norm was going
to come on and do either tol sto or
Dusty and he agreed to do it and then
coid happened and shut everything down
and then we were leaving California and
I said said hey Norm you know just
circling back on this if you can do it I
said oh yeah I'm happy to and I said
okay well here's the address you and he
says oh I can't go into a studio right
now I could do it by you know Skype or
something but I can't I can't go into a
studio and I thought he was just being
agoraphobic he had kind of a reputation
for that and I said no we'll send your
car he goes no I really can't go out
right now and I said okay well maybe
we'll get it later you know I'll fly
back to LA or something and thought
we'll get it after coid whatever and
then he died before coid because he
unbeknown anybody had cancer and then I
found out I kind of went back in the
timeline and realized he was he was
undergoing cancer treatment like that
week or something or certainly within
the few weeks around that filming and
but he didn't I obviously didn't know
that I would have had him do it on Skype
or uh yeah that would have been
certainly the best episode of that show
all of these clips though these are the
best late night Clips ever once you
watch this now just go down the rabbit
hole see you next time goodbye goodbye
so so Longwell farewell do
stay
byee